[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild 11 februar
1991 in italien feiert man Karneval auch
in San Luca in
Kalabrien junge Männer der Familien
stranio nirta und pelomeo albn betrunken
herum und bewerfen sich mit Eiern aus
Eiern werden wenig später Böller dann
artet der Spaß in eine brutale
Schlägerei aus hier könnte die
Geschichte als dorfprügelei enden aber
San Luca ist ein Epizentrum der
Mafiaorganisation drangetta und die
beteiligten Familien sind deren Bosse
und weil das so ist fängt hier erst eine
lange Geschichte an sie führt unter
anderem dazu dass 16 Jahre und 185 Tage
später bei Bildreporter Frank Schneider
mitten in der Nacht das Telefon klingelt
ich kann mich noch sehr gut daran
erinnern ich hatte damals nachts auch
wirklich immer mein Handy an 24 Stunden
und dann ging mein Handy früh morgens
und ich bin dran gegangen und hatte
einen dran heute kann man es erzählen
ist sozusagen verjhrt der Polizeifunk
abhörte heute ist das ja nicht mehr
möglich und sagte zu mir du musst
schnell aufstehen wir haben fünf Tote in
Duisburg und mein erster Gedanke war ein
schwerer Verkehrsunfall irgendwo gegen
Baum gefahren junge Leute nach der Disco
und sagte dann auch zu dem Kollegen ja
wo sind die denn gegen gefahren und er
sagte nee nirgendwo gegen Gefahren die
sind erschossen worden und das werde ich
nie vergessen die es Gefühl fünf Leute
erschossen ich habe dann auch sofort
gesagt da musst du dich verhört haben
das kann nicht sein fünf Leute
erschossen und hab dann den Hörer
D nachtr wieder in die Hand genommen
nachdem ich aufgelegt habe und den
Pressesprecher der Polizei angerufen der
damals nachts auch immer für uns
erreichbar war habe den geweckt und da
dachte ich in dem Moment schon als der
verschlafen dran ging na ja das kann
nicht stimmen weil wenn was wäre wäde ja
schon wach und in dem Moment wo auch zu
mir sagt mal weißt du wie viel Uhr es
ist und ich so ja ihr habt angebl ich
fünf Tote in Duisburg weiß ich nichts
von klingelt im Hintergrund sein
Festnetztelefon und er sagt nur mist ich
glaube du hast recht das die Leitstelle
legte dann auf und rief m Z Minuten
später zurück und sagte hast doch nicht
recht sind nicht fünf sind sechs mehrere
Tote liegen vor dem Restaurant da Bruno
in der Nähe des Duisburger Hauptbahnhofs
anders als in anderen Großstädten ist
das Bahnhofsviertel hier nicht
schmuddelig sondern eher gediegen hier
residieren Anwälte Ärzte und
Unternehmensberater aber im Morgengrauen
des 15 August 2007 herrscht hier das
pure Grauen das war wie eine szeneria ja
wie ein Drehort von einem Tatort oder
von irgendeinem skandinavischen Krimi
die halt immer besonders brutal sind da
lagen halt wirklich fünf Personen auf
der Straße waren alle noch nicht
abgedeckt in so einer
Hofeinfahrt Wiesen viele Schusswunden
auf dahinter standen zwei Fahrzeuge die
waren regelrecht durchsiebt von Kugeln
es war wirklich wie von eben von eine
Mafia Film ja damals wussten es ja zu
diesem frühen Moment noch nicht aber der
Verdacht kam sofort auf als es eben
neben dieser Pizzeria war ja und dann
stand man da und eins habe ich wirklich
nie vergessen können das hat mich auch
so ein bisschen verfolgt
einer der Toten war noch sehr jung
hinter kam raus der war 16 der sah aber
gefühlt sogar noch jünger aus und er lag
auf diesem Asphalt und man er sah eben
aus als würde er hätte sich daingelegt
der wäre gar nicht tot weil die so
frisch tot waren dass sie natürlich noch
nicht noch nicht die Leichenstarre und
blass waren sie auch noch nicht und
während ich dann da gestanden aber es
hat lange gedauert bis man die Leichen
abgedeckt hat
sah man dann wie irgendwann die Lippen
anfingen weiß zu werden und das werde
ich wirklich nie vergessen es war
wirklich so das Leben entwich aus diesem
Körper und das empfand ich damals als
unglaublich schrecklich und schlimm
dieses zu sehen und der wirkte halt so
jung wie gesagt mit 16 ist man natürlich
auch noch jung das fand ich damals
wirklich schrecklich muss ich wirklich
sagen was also war passiert das
vordergründige ließ sich relativ schnell
ermitteln das wer das wo und das wann am
14 August 2007 trafen sich der Wirt des
da Bruno Sebastiano S und sein Lehrling
Tomaso Francesco V mit vier weiteren
Verwandten des wirzs im Restaurant um zu
feiern denn der Lehrling wurde um
Mitternacht 18 man isst und trinkt bis
ca 2 Uhr dann wird der Laden
abgeschlossen und die Männer machen sich
daran mit zwei Autos loszufahren aber
vor dem Restaurant an der
mülheimerstraße warten bewaffnete Männer
im Dunkeln und eröffnen das Feuer auf
die Festgesellschaft sie geben 54
Schüsse ab um 2 Uhr 24 geht der Notruf
bei der Polizei ein 6 Minuten später ist
der erste Streifenwagen da wenig später
auch bildmann Frank Schneider solche
Fälle bei denen man so früh dabei ist
die vergisst man nicht sagt er ja ich
glaube das ist das ganz entscheidendes
dass gerade wir bei Bild auch wirklich
immer vorort sein wollen und selber eben
ein Bild machen wollen und natürlich ist
das emotional was ganz anderes das zieht
ein ganz anders in diese Geschichte rein
es lässt einen diese Geschichte auch
ganz anders erleben und eben auch das
das grausame und schreckliche dieses
Verbrechens bekommt man ganz anders mit
als wenn man es nur auf Papier oder am
Telefon mitbekommt und auch zu sehen die
ganze aufwende Spurensicherung und was
mich damals auch wirklich beeindruckt
hat war das blanke Entsetzen auch bei
den Polizeibeamten die machen jeden Tag
Tötungsdelikte von der Mordkommission
aber auch die waren mit der Situation
mehr oder weniger überfordert der
sechste Tod ist auf dem Weg ins
Krankenhaus ist der Mann gestorben die
Meldung kam ja dann eben auch noch
hinterher und äh man hat den wirklich
angemerkt auch die war mit der Situation
erstmal völlig überfordert auch am
nächsten Tag bei der Pressekonferenz die
dann stattfand ja und so fragen sich
alle in den nächsten Stunden und Tagen
was da eigentlich passiert ist vor dem
da Bruno die Öffentlichkeit die Kripo
und natürlich Polizeireporter Frank
Schneider war das ein Raubüberfall oder
irgendeine Beziehungstat wir hatten dann
über unsere
Kontakte nach Italien schon rausbekommen
dass es eben um einen langen schwähenden
mafiastreit ging zwischen zwei
mafiafilien und die Polizei in Duisburg
die natürlich erstmal AK Arbeit und die
Kontakt ja nicht so direkt hat die
können da nicht in Italien anrufen die
müssen das über das Bundeskriminalamt
und Auswärtige Amt machen und hatten
noch keine Erkenntnisse und bei der
Pressekonferenz war so absurd dass
eigentlich die Polizei nichts wusste und
wir schon ganz viel und das war wirklich
eine ganz surale Situation die Sprachen
auch dann davon ja das muss man erstmal
abwarten vielleicht ist es auch eine
Eifersuchtsgeschichte wo wir alle gesagt
haben wer erschießt denn fünf Leute
wegen der Eifersuchtsgeschichte bzw
sech ja das war war sehr sal man sah
auch damals dass die Polizei von dieser
Situation komplett Asch noch überrollt
wurde nachdem die Presse schon früh
Kontakte nach Italien aktiviert tut es
die Polizei auch denn natürlich stimmt
Frank Schneiders Verdacht das Massaker
von Duisburg hat seinen Ursprung in
Kalabrien hier war eine Abrechnung unter
Mafiosi gemacht worden eine alte fede
zog ihre blutige Spur in die Gegenwart
und um die zu verstehen gehen wir jetzt
mal ganz weit zurück noch vor die
Geschichte mit den Böllern und der
Schlägerei
um das Jahr 1850 tun sich Arbeitslose
Soldaten Wegelagerer und Rebellen im
süditalienischen Kalabrien zusammen sie
begehen gemeinsam Erpressungen Überfälle
und Entführungen anfänglich wird diese
kriminelle Vereinigung noch poteria
genannt übersetzt in etwa Club junger
Burschen später setzt sich der Begriff
drangetta durch hier ist die
Wortherkunft nicht ganz klar
möglicherweise bilden die echischen
Wörter für Mann und heldenhaft den
Ursprung und natürlich trifft das
Gegenteil von heldenhaft zu das ist von
Anfang an ein übler krimineller Haufen
Kalabrien ist arm und die Leute hassen
die Herrschenden im fernen Rom also
bildet die nangeta eine
parallelherrschaft dominiert die
Lokalpolitik und die örtliche Wirtschaft
sie erpresst Schutzgelder und kassiert
für die Nutzung von Straßen oder für
Baugenehmigung später kommen
Drogenhandel und
dazu aber weil Kalabrien so arm und
unbedeutend wirkt nimmt kaum jemand ih
dranketa wah ganz im Gegensatz zu den
berühmten mafiaabünden kamora und
kosanostra das ändert sich erst in den
1970er Jahren da wird der verschwiegene
Club mächtiger es gibt in dieser Zeit
aber auch eine tödliche Krise ein Streit
um Einnahmen eskaliert und fordert von
1974 bis
1976 mehr als 230
leben das ist tragisch und blutig aber
vor allem schadet es dem Geschäft zwei
Familien erobn danach die Spitze dieser
dunklen Organisation und teilen sich die
Macht die Clans tranetta und Pelle Romeo
aus dem Dorf San Luca sie sind übrigens
vielfach verschwägert und verschwistert
was die Ermittlungen später manchmal
ziemlich kompliziert macht und damit
sind wir wieder beim Streit mit den
Eiern und faschingsböllern im Februar
1991 sich den Anfang machen angeblich
junge Leute der stranion nertas und
bewerfen ein Lokal der
peleromeos statt den Streit frühzeitig
zu schlichten setzen die Bosse auf
Eskalation kurz nach dem karnevalszof
werden zwei Burschen der strano Seite
erschossen jetzt gibt es kein Zurück
mehr denn hinter sinnlos wirkenden
Böllern und Eiern steckt in Wahrheit ein
neuer Machtkampf der schon lange in der
Luft liegt es geht um Reviere Märkte
posten und wieder um Milliardengewinne
und so belauern sich beide Seiten immer
wieder kommt es zu Überfällen
Hinterhalten und Attentaten irgendwann
ab Mitte der 90er Jahre beruhigt sich
die Lage deutlich die italienische
Polizei geht ab dem Jahr 2000 sogar
davon aus dass die sogenannte San Luca
fede beigelegt werden konnte offenbar
haben beide Seiten erkannt dass Drogen
Prostitution und Geldwäsche mehr bringen
als Streit in diesen Jahren erweitert
die dranketta übrigens ihr
Einflussgebiet nach Deutschland aus aber
mit friedfreude Eierkuchen ist ab 2005
schon wieder Schluss ein Mitglied des
pevotari Clans hat sich gegenüber einer
stranoau bedrohlich aufgeführt und wird
erschossen im Gegenzug schießt der
pevotari Clan auf einen Mann der
Gegenseite und tötet ihn und von da an
wird das Gemetzel sozusagen noch
hochkarätiger denn als nächst schießen
die stranirtas auf Francesco Pelle einen
Boss der Gegenseite Pelle ist fort an
Querschnitts gelehmt er ordnet Rache an
und die mündet im sogenannten
weihnachtsmord von 2006 der Pelle Romeo
Clan attackiert seine Gegner mitten in
San Luca dabei wird die 33-Jährige Maria
strano getötet drei weitere Angehörige
ihrer Familie werden verletzt darunter
ein Kind das ist die Ausgangslage vor
dem Geschehen in Duisburg zwei
mafiafilien haben das Kriegsbeil
ausgegraben und wieder mal zahlreiche
Gegner abgeknallt und alle sind gespannt
was als nächstes passiert die Behörden
in Italien sind also vorgewarnt und
überwachen zahlreiche mafffiosi und
deren Handys wer jetzt die nächste
Eskalation startet muss mit seiner
Verhaftung rechnen es könnte also schlau
sein den nächsten Schachzug im Ausland
zu machen Deutschland ist zu diesem
Zeitpunkt schon lange ein wichtiger
Rückzugsraum für die drangetta hier kann
man sich prima verstecken und hier kann
man in Restaurants oder im und
Exportfirmen schmutziges Geld waschen
auch die blutige fede verlagert sich
jetzt hierhin die strano nirtas
beobachten genau wer wo ist und so
dürfen sie auch gewusst haben dass sich
Marco Mo in Duisburg aufhielt Mo soll
der weihnachtsmörder von 2006 gewesen
sein also der Mann der Maria strano
erschoss ihre Familie entschließt sich
im Sommer 2007 zu einer bis dahin
unvorstellbaren Maßnahme die nächste
Blutrache soll im Ausland stattfinden in
Deutschland und damit sind wir wieder im
Morgengrauen des 15 August 2007
Blaulicht blinkt über die noch fast
menschenleere
mülheimerstraße polizisten sichern
Spuren die Leichen werden
abtransportiert Bildreporter Frank
Schneider beginnt mit seinen Recherchen
in den Tagen darauf vervollständigen
Kollegen aus Italien das Bild dass sich
die deutsche Polizei macht und auch die
Ermittlungen selbst machen Fortschritte
z.B haben Überwachungskameras im
Nebengebäude das Scheinwerferlicht des
täterautos gefilmt es kann durch eine
spezielle lichtanalyse identifiziert
werden italienische mafiajäger Steuern
viele Erkenntnisse bei sie haben unter
anderem ein Telefonat des drangetta
Bosses giovan strano abgehört als er die
Tötung der Mörder seiner Cousine Maria
ankündigte die die deutsche Polizei kann
seine DNA schließlich nach der Tat in
einem Düsseldorfer Hotel sichern
zeitweise Arbeiten 120 Beamte in NRW an
dem Fall die Polizei braucht zwar einen
langen Atem aber der zahlt sich aus ein
Jahr nach der Tat wurde stranjos
Schwager giseppa nta in Holland
festgenommen also der Mann der
Ermordeten Maria stranjo und im Jahr
darauf schnappte die niederländische
Polizei in Amsterdam auch den
mutmaßlichen Haupttäter von Duisburg
Giovanni sano bei einem Prozess im
kalabrischen lokri wurde er 2011 zu
lebenslanger Haft verurteilt und auch in
die Gegenrichtung blieb die italienische
Justiz aktiv so wurde im Oktober 2008
der Anführer der verfeindeten Familie
pelomeo festgenommen also Francesco den
seine Gegner in den Rollstuhl geschossen
hatten und der den Mord an Maria in
Auftrag gegeben haben soll also in
diesem blutigen Spektakel ist es ehrlich
gesagt wie Mafia Film es gibt ohne Ende
Verlierer und Tote und trotzdem geht es
immer weiter und so ähnlich fällt das
Fazit auch bei Bildreporter Frank
Schneider aus ja man muss sagen dass das
damals eigentlich der größte
Betriebsunfall war den die drangetta
machen konnte die italienische Mafia aus
cabrien weil das hat die Polizei und
natürlich auch die Politik massiv
nachhaltig aufgescheucht und gesagt das
kann es nicht sein so sowas können wir
hier in Deutschland nicht zulassen und
dann gab es eben die Ermittlung auch den
Austausch mit den italienischen Behörden
und schnell wurde klar wie wichtig
Deutschland für die drangetta ist wie
wichtig auch der Weg ist die drangetta
ist führend im Kokainhandel und das
kommt häufig vom rotterdammer Hafen und
wird dann Wirich mehr oder weniger nach
ganz Europa verteilt und das Deutschland
ein ganz ganz wichtiger Ort und
Deutschland ist deshalb auch so wichtig
für sie weil dort Geld gewaschen wird
die drangetta muss natürlich wirklich
Milliarden waschen das können sie
alleine in Italien nicht das würde viel
zu sehr auffallen denn dort sind die
antimafia Gesetze ja relativ streng und
das sind sie in Deutschland eben nicht
die deutsche Politik muss man sagen hat
eigentlich immer noch nicht wirklich
erkannt wie gefährlich das ist und
das Ergebnis sieht man auch daran das
ist jetzt mittlerweile ja äh ja 15 Jahre
her und wenn man dann rückwirkend sieht
wie die Polizei damals vorgegangen ist
wie es auch aufklärungsstrukturen gab
ratzien gab Festnahmen gab hat man das
Gefühl dass es komplett wieder
eingeschlafen denn im Unterschied zu
Clans tritt die italienische Mafia ganz
bewusst nicht sichtbar auf das war
damals wie gesagt eine Art
Betriebsunfall und heute arbeiten sie
wieder im im verdeckten Bereich und ich
habe vor zwei Jahren ein der antimafia
Staatsanwälte in Italien immer treffen
können und hab den eine Woche begleitet
ähm der unter massiven Personenschutz
lebt der wirklich keinen Schritt vor die
Haustür machen kann seine Familie nicht
das Militär bewacht sein Haus in dem er
lebt das kann man mit hier überhaupt
nicht vergleichen und er hat auch gesagt
das Problem ist dass die deutschen
Behörden es einfach nicht wahrhen wollen
auch die deutsche Politik nicht er hat
hier eine Rundreise gemacht er hat das
allen erklärt wie verherend das ist auch
für die italienischen antimafiabehörden
dass die Deutschen nichts machen weil
wenn das Geld weiter gewaschen werden
kann und darum geht's der Mafia es geht
einfach um diese wahnsinnigen Gewinne
und die müssen halt sauber werden dann
können Sie in Italien noch so viel
machen wie sie wollen wenn die Deutschen
nicht mitziehen ist es ein echtes
Problem und stand jetzt ziehen sie nicht
mit die drangetteter hat absolut gelernt
die deutschen Behörden und insbesondere
die deutsche Politik leider Gottes
überhaupt nicht und damit sind wir am
Ende der heutigen Episode angelangt wir
danken euch fürs zuhören und freuen uns
wenn ihr auch beim nächsten Mal wieder
dabei seid und falls Ihr Anregungen
Kritik habt oder fallvorschläge ja dann
schreibt uns gerne eine E-Mail oder
schreibt uns Nachrichten bei Instagram
die Links dazu haben wir euch natürlich
auch noch in die showotes gepackt die
Geschichte der Vendetta von Duisburg
haben wir erzählt mit Informationen von
Bild Welt WZ Tagesspiegel und Tatz
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und Frank
Schneider Postproduktion durch wwor
Studios München Schnitt die glorreiche
Tony haer bis bald euer Milko und eure
Tony dir hat diese Folge von Tat
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Rusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Hermann wir hören uns bei tatout
Deutschland